NIGHT IN A TIGHT LOSS AGAINST
THE SON
BETWEEN THESE TWO TEAMS.
DIFFERENT SEASON.
EVEN THOUGH THEIR RECORDS ARE
SIMILAR.
OH, WHAT A FIND.
ARIZA, ABLE TO FIN DEFENSE SET.
>> Ryan: NEW ORLEANS, EIGHTH IN.
SINK FROM
ANTHONY AND
TURNOVERS GUYS ARE STILL ON THE
SPONSORING THE BROADCAST.
WINDOW WITH THE LEFT MIDDLE TWO
QUARTERS.
OFFENSIVELY.
RANKED 24th IN THE LEAGUE IN  G.
AS PIZZAZZ.
AS GRAHAM CAN'T HIT THE THREE. ?
>> Ryan: I'M WAITING FOR LeBRON.
41-35, PELICANS
INGRAM, THE FORMER LAKER.
QUARTER, REAVES SPARKED THAT ME
COACH DAVID  STAKES FOR
BOTH TEAMS.
ACL
BEFORE SIGNING A BIG CONTRACT.
S
SETTLE IN ON UP THE
GLASS, DWIWI OF JUST NOTN A ROU
RUSS.
>> Ryan: J
THE FIRST HALF.
LAKERS DOWN 17.
25-POINT GAME.HILE ARE BRINGING
ELLINGTON IN FOR THE FIRST TIME
TONIGHT.T. WHIPS IT SHOTS AT TH
RIM THAT HAVE
FIGURE IT OUT, NONE OF THE
THINGS ARE COMPUTING.HALF, GOLD
STATE WAS UP 19NG OUT WITH
US ON A SUNDAY NIGHT.
ATRANGE SITUATION.
BUT RUSSSS
>> Ryan: 25-POA 9-0 RUN IN THE
MINUTES. THIS GROUP.
WHICH CAN BE BEN McCOLLUM
MIDSEASON, IT WAS YOU
NEED AS AN OFFICIAL.
>> Richard: PROBABLY MOST OF
THEM ARE
PELICANS
I WOULD IMAGINE, RICHARD, YOU
>> Ryan: YEAH.
REAVES, LOOKS LIKE HE JUST HURT
HIMSELF.